Ukraine and Russia have carried out a
prisoner swap with Russia releasing over
200 prisoners of war in return for 55
Russians and Ukrainian oligarch and
Putin associate Victor medvedchuk ten
foreigners were among the prisoners
handed over by Russia including five
British and two U.S Nationals who were
flown to Saudi Arabia many of the
Ukrainian prisoners had been captured
during the siege of mariupo
all right well let's turn to our
correspondent Emmanuel Shaz who's in
kharkiv in northeastern Ukraine hi
Emmanuel good to see you so a
significant and perhaps unexpected
development that had to involve a great
deal of negotiation right
exactly Pablo first off you might hear
behind me there's the National Anthem
being played here all over Harkey if it
happens every day it is played in a
memory of the soldiers of Ukraine who
lost their lives during this life and
how not to think about the more than 50
soldiers who recently died on July 29th
in the prison of olinifka in donede this
had been a national trauma and waking up
to the news of the liberation of
215 prisoners or for including over a
hundred prisoners Who had who were part
of the azer of Battalion who defended
Mario Paul well this came as a much
needed and pleasant surprise here for
ukrainians yesterday evening as the news
started to be published to be made
official I can tell you there's not one
Ukrainian person I'm in contact with who
didn't you know erupt with joy social
media was full of celebrations uh this
is this wasn't expected we knew
negotiations were on the way turkey and
Saudi Arabia played a role there with as
our style commanders uh five as our
style commanders being in Turkey right
now then they're forbidden to go back to
Ukraine those were the times of the
agreements but I think a lot of relief
here on the Ukrainian side
um well the music has stopped there for
you Emmanuel so uh maybe you can hear us
a little bit better was Ukraine's
negotiating stance do you think
bolstered by their recent gains on the
field
well uh you know uh when
um so so it was an exchange of prisoner
55 Russian prisoners were returned to
Russia including Victor Midwest Midwest
who's a lawmaker who was charged with
high treason here in Ukraine uh he's a
he's putting his clothes Ally and when
he was made prisoner a few months ago
Vladimir zelensky Ukrainian president
had suggested an exchange of prisoner
and the Kremlin had absolutely ruled
that out back then now those
negotiations took place again at a
moment where Ukraine is gaining momentum
on the field at the moment with where
it's counter-offensive is going quite
well so we can see there that Ukraine is
having the upper hand and perhaps this
has led to the success of those
negotiations among the people liberated
so as of style Defenders also pregnant
women a military personnel a pregnant
military were re release a lot of people
also who were you know those pictures we
saw back in May of emaciated soldiers so
this is really a moment of Joy here in
Ukraine with the president of Vladimir
zelenski saying that Ukraine was not
leaving its soldiers behind
W correspondent to Manuel Shaz in harkiv
thank you